this video is brought to you by better help as two
people who have been in therapy for many years now
we are proud to be partnered with these [Music]
guys citizens of the reject Nation I have a very
important message for everyone before we watch
the finale of hasbin Hotel Roxy claims to read
every single one of the comments on these videos
let's put this to the test I want to really see
if she's the real deal ask her some questions
in the comments let's see if she responds I
hope you respond to every single one of them
I respond to nice people who want to talk to
me and I do read every single comment let's
see guys we're here for the finale very very
excited we had some predictions that we laid down
in the uh episode 7 let's see if any of them come
true hey yo leave a like that would be very much
appreciated thanks preer for helping us edit down
these highlights thank you to all who have follow
us at our patreon page becoming super sexy rejects
over there you get the full length retion watch
sink up with your own copy of hasman Hotel John
and Greg I am Greg do sever shows exclusively
over there with Hots and watch songs included
and now let's ver Journey ver Journey let's can't
wait to V Journey with you guys to the depths of
[Music]
hell I can't believe this is
finale the dream who is this oh is this TV boy no
way they're going to [__] right oh my God I love
this guy looks like your little hotel didn't work
out so well oh aliser I cannot wait to watch you
get oh this is written by Adam Stein different so
Vivan didn't write this one I wish my mom was here
to see this me too I know begging for that Lilith
DPC ready for victorious combat what in the hell
are you supposed to be General penious reporting
for Duty I'll turn those wrapped scallions into
soul solders in no time at all really he has grown
on me so much I love him base seats fortifications
reinforce the Southern Wall create a moot around
the perimeter to stop a ground assault okay the
dead rats if you see an angel stab it no nope nope
hey hey heyy not him oh that's angel dust Sinners
we got 24 hours before the extermination begins
let's get to work Stephie beatric I still feel
like is an underrated Talent honestly I wonder how
she feels internally about killing her own kind
Stephanie beatress no vagy I wasn't responding
to what you said I was watching the show but
you're right even people who aren't staying
here yet Cherry look I can't resist to fight
okay especially when I get to tag team with this
oh my God they're all coming together yes and we
are we are going to win but in case we don't no
I want you all to know that getting to know you
has been the biggest honor of my life that's sweet
but don't put doubt in there I know you all tried
I have seen the good in all of you you mean these
like five people live tonight however you want
because that's die all right let's give it up for
not dying love not dying drinks oh the celebratory
night before a courageous Last Stand a surprising
thrill to witness these Wayward Souls find
connection I really like them Alister
they let me put on roach puppet shows
without booing ah an enjoyable Collective
to be around uhhuh I dub thee King roach
oh to understand your Twisted little mind that's
disgusting oh no okay I'm like waiting for it
yeah and you're not off snorting a l off some
hunks ABS one cannibal po boy them yeah I
know what you mean man Charlie said live
tonight however we wanted make out so pour
me a fresh one and let's get to living you
don't want to be inebriated when you're going
to battle Cherry tell her I want to tell you
that I tell her I love I'd love to wish you
good luck in the battle serenes you are have
always been a worthy opponent with the most
brilliant explosive this is like the Ross
and Rachel of the show well they won't they
anyway I guess please don't die tomorrow okay
bye don't be gross don't be
gross you know I hear he's
got well how do you want me to respond to
that Craig yes I'll take one
of them what if we lose you
yes true Oh
yay
facts heavy tell
her that's
enough marry me yeah [Music] what I mean
they're doing the more than anything sign
but what have they not said to each other they
love each other more than anything a oh I got
happy nipple chills I didn't know nipple chills
came in the happy variety no well they usually
come in excited Goose Adam is demon like just
the most ridiculous character Slaughter every
in that [__] hotel and you all remember V
it's vagy mouth out her ass you just chill
loot I want Adam to get his ass handed to him
so bad is he gonna live through this season
no come on let's go go let's go oh this is
good be good now for your souls Angel dust's
boss was there with the TV guy Valentino
yeah let the slaughter begin get in there
[Music] Alistair they appear to have some
kind of Shield sir oh really I didn't see
this giant shield in front of me you dumb [__]
no [__] yes all Angelic weapons fire at will
hey yelling while fighting doesn't help uh I
mean you need to talk over it sounds Al Shield
is working uhoh don't say something's
working otherwise damn baggy looks good
this Adam has power yeah well he
was the [Music] first oh this the
first time they' be coming face to
face Adam first man next to die who
the [__] are you Alis pleasure to be
meeting you quite a pleasure I'm about
to end youring life I can't help but I love
Alistar I'm going to be devastated if he's
evil you really think you can take me on a mortal
soul is no match for me EDG Lord this a cool
fight you think you're tough [__]
huh tougher than you and worst you're
sloppy get him you you red piece of you
much red shut up too much red I'm going
to wipe that [__] eating grin off
your face cuz radio is dead what just
happened no oh you Alis this is than sex I did
not expect that disagree with you there radio's
not dead but it is ending this broadcast
ooh that was interesting Adam's stronger
get ready for yeah You' have to assume he
was strong name but got it vagatha it's
like Agatha she's a apologizing she probably
has the most power if she doesn't realize
it oh my God
gramble you all right squirt get somewhere
safe [Music] my damn this is wild this is
a full-blown fight we aren't going to last long
unless we do something about him oh no of course
serenus no he's the only one that I think might
die fight in mind yes yay he's got two dingling
I love you he said it remember me that was kind
of hard I hope he doesn't die kind of love him
now and charge the death ray yes sires crazy
mother I love how this is coming full circle
yeah everything's like tying back to the first
couple [Music] episodes oh jeez you did good
buddy Charlie I'm so sorry no there's going to
be more to [Music] it yeah least go there it
is let's run yep House of the Dragons
there's that Darkness look who thinks
they're badass she is the traitor
came to die no oh God before I
take your life I'm going to tear that
other eye out of your face was like
Kook jeez this is really good action it's like
an anime faggies surprise [__] unleash who you
really are risking your Immortal Life for Sinners
these Sinners are my family these Sinners are by
my family he is the worst you should have stayed
in your place girly yes that's princess of hell
to you pig the [__] that hurts can make him
bleed oh tail you always were weak no [Music] no
yes
do it then correct your mistake seriously
you're pathetic you know that carai live
knowing that you only do because I let you
oh I would love to say that to someone I
think of at least three people yeah but is
she stuck under there or oh god oh no this
fight was cute and all but it's time
to die with the rest of them Charlie
yes okay seriously how many of you freaks
do I have to fight oh wa there's a whole
face under there see you messed with my
daughter and now I am going to [__] you
well this just got interesting [__] you
up Dad wait what did I say now I'm going
to you're the most hated being in
all of creation well your first
wife didn't seem to hate what I had to off the
second nice stke douchebag Hold
Still You slippery but where is
aliser no oh God Hotel I got you Dad look
out yeah a you come at me and my you're in
my house [__] that was a cool shot his house
as hell who who dad he's had enough no murder
I'm theing man and you're just someing clown
or something I started everything on Earth all
of mankind came from these fing nuts these nuts
disgusting fuing losers whoa oh my God oh my God
[Music] not I like that that was an amazing
reveal that's amazing take your little friends
and go home I think he makes it Retreat all
exorcists fall back oh my God it's going to be
full-blown War next season God's going going to
get involved so who's up for pancakes I haven't
had pancakes in years I had pancakes this week
oh you looked great for having pancakes the
janitor saide Charlie told me to stab so I did
congrats to Charlie and her crew for not being
totally useless for once a where's Alister well
there's still something big is going to happen I
think he did it for us a final song the ultimate
but but he's alive we don't [Music] know
do what you [Music] could did better than
usual why the frown you're the first one
to change this time yes you can do this
now I know it for your story is just
begun Seas toe you've changed my mind
you've touched their hearts found
the good and souls gone bad she's a
great woman the crowd is gone but by God
Charlie the show it must go on must go
on greater [Music]
tell would this motivation
for Redemption be the same
in look at them they're all doing it
together of's ruins news across withcer
a they're all positive Al missing fled
with his tail between his legs what the
future of Hell belongs to the no this place
of there's a chill the and bar escaped being
killed by a hair it's going to come back
stronger sorry to disappoint that is not
where this ends no I'm hungry for free
like never before the constraints of my
deal surely have a back door what is the
deal I don't know he wants to get out of
hell oh he wants to be the ruler
yeah but uncp your wings from who
got to be Lilith right gotta [Applause]
be Al's [Music] back good day in [Music]
hello
no what Redemption that's crazy Adam is dead
your deal is done and I'm in charge now is
it who I think it is your Brad is threatening
the very Foundation of heaven and if you want
to stay here yeah you're brat you're going
down there and stop that bding in heaven
you understand me Lilith yeah it's exact
almost exactly how we thought they would
tease Lilith where he talk you kept saying this
whole season they didn't cast her yet so You'
see a little bit of her but then they would
it would be the final moment so she's hiding
out on the beach wow and Adam is dead dead she's
worse than everyone else she mad in her daughter
that's cruel selfish she enjoying life damn for
once Prime video recommends something that kind
of makes sense a little Nicki lines up yeah
that actually lines up a lot that does make
sense yeah wow and you and I love him I know
Sandman I also love today's sponsor thank you
to better help for sponsoring this video I've
literally just finished a therapy session and
I wanted to shoot this cuz I'm in this state of
knowing why I Champion mental health supports so
much in the past few weeks work's been a little
bit hectic it's led me to miss some sessions and
I really don't like doing that and sometimes
that's when the weight really starts to pile
on a lot of restless nights a lot of fatigue a
lot of I can't sleep even though I'm so tired
sometimes just a very deep-seated sense of Gloom
meditating and sometimes journaling are my daily
go-to but sometimes they just don't cut it when
I'm trying to pinpoint why I'm down and really
especially after a session like today therapy
just really helps clear the fog discussing the
feelings is a critical step for me especially as
someone who's diagnosed with ADHD type 2 bipolar
and PTSD it's truly a Cornerstone to my well-being
and I'm not alone in this many of us here at real
rejects are in therapy facing our own challenges
from depression to anxiety or just needing a
non-judgmental space to voice our thoughts this
year I've been working on most days of the week
to keep my physical health strong and I really
do Champion therapy as a way to strengthen my
mental resilience and for many better help is
integral to that process There's real value in
better help's accessible and adaptable service
they match you with the licensed therapist
and provide the option to switch if necessary
ensuring the right fit for your mental health
Journey as this year winds down and we confront
life's complexities do consider betterhelp as a
resource really happy to be partnered with them
this month so you can go to betterhelp.com sreal
rejects for 10% off your first month again that's
b t r h lp.com slre rejects so join us in moving
forward stronger together thank you again and I
also love that Roxy be wearing rejected material
around here oh yeah baby a sooka a soda yeah I
think this one of our most underrated shirts but
not our space PS of the Galaxy I spread my legs
for for some reason now stay I'm rubbing off
on I want this one uh do you want this one I
just love how that's what everyone does when
they come here give me that give me a shirt no
we're talking about the shirts I'm say I want
this one it's really cool yeah sure I didn't say
give me oh my God Greg I got let me hype up your
shirts like it's so cool I want this one do you
want this one that's what I said well I got I've
got three more in development right now going to
be what are they I don't want to ruin it I want
to ruin it are any of them Purge related yeah that
is just like a boom in thing here everyone knows
Purge my Purge pillows on the ground I'm sorry to
hear that uh all right well we've made it to the
finale of hasman hotel if you're listening to this
on Apple or Spotify uh we watched episodes seven
and eight back to back a lot of our things that
we I mean the main thing with Lilith I I guess I
wasn't expecting her to be in heaven uh which is
kind of surprising but nothing really surp it's
weird like surprising things don't even surprise
me because the show can kind of just it has car
blanch to sort of do whatever the hell they want
are we sure that was Heaven she go the angel goes
up and says if you want to stay here where the
hell else would it be oh she could be on Earth
yeah oh it was a beach yeah it was a beach right
oh damn too people probably commented and then the
ad played and then they're like no Greg it's not
heaven a damn I don't know it could be Heaven no
you're probably right I don't know that right
I'm just saying we we know she's not in Hell
clearly and we know she wants to stay there she
Paradise you know she's having a parist par paral
is there like a verb for par for experience in
Paradise par paral she's getting the dickle and
perah yeah that sounds like something else yeah
I think that I'm not sure where exactly she is
but what we do know is she's not in Hell taking
care of her daughter she's not showing up for her
daughter the way Lucifer is showing up for the
daughter uh she clearly has some deal with the
angels that she is able to be where she is for as
long as hell stays tame you know and but then now
they're like you can't stay here unless you go
take care of that [__] but who has the power
over it seems like she want has nothing to do with
any of that [__] in hell so why would she be the
one reigning over Alistair I don't know that she
is reigning over aliser it's just been my theory
this whole time because they were gone for the
same amount of time no it pokes a it does yeah
it sounds like like there was some there there's
some other Lynch pin some other conduit for all
this stuff you know yeah because and then even
Alistar song at the end like clipped my wings
mhm from who we need answers but in terms of a
finale it was action-packed action-packed yeah
I mean they set up this the season they were like
we're gonna heaven and hell are going to fight and
then the finale Heaven and Hell fought and then
there's chances of redemption my question that
was the biggest reveal of serenes yeah he went
like this was her plan the whole time and sent
just sacrifices himself for his friends truly
truly does the selfless thing and he shows up
in heaven and if you factor in the pilot as
a true episode one he was the first villain
right so the full character Arc but he kisses
Cherry Bomb and he says I love you and then he
goes off and he does something very brave and
it doesn't work but he does it why end up in
heaven but the plan why why I guess I guess my
question is no one wants this purge thing to
happen anymore right Purge yep no no one wants it
to happen anymore and it's like poking to Teddy
Bears um bir it's different when you're like face
to face with the just like right your eyes bir
bir uh yeah the no one wants this to happen no
one wants it to happen happen this extermination
and you know they want us to get the hotel going
again which they have already done what would be
the greater purpose of Rehabilitation when the
goal before was uh to eliminate The Purge from
happening and just hear you saying eliminate
eliminated from happening I mean the idea was
like okay you prevent less people from from
being excised if if more people are able to go
to heaven because of the overpopulation problem
right would the goal still be to get you to go
to heaven because clearly now that Charlie knows
what heaven's really like that it's not all it's
made out to be would they want to want to go to
heaven or or would it just be about making hell
a more you know a stronger Community well in
heaven you don't have the risk of extermination
well I think the I think in this finale what
they were showing was they don't even want that
extermination element to be happening in hell so
I they have a bigger goal in their hands of of a
war there has to be some type of deal made
with heaven where they're not killing each
other killing anyone in hell um right because hell
serenus probably doesn't want to be there and they
don't probably want him there yeah CU hell's just
more of a community it's not it's not in the same
way of how hell has been pitched to us for so long
of like souls go there and then they're punished
and they're tortured they're they're just uh it's
a civilization essentially some of them but we saw
the v's you know you can be punished uh but you
can also just live there you know maybe unless the
v's are in charge true you know like under under
Charlie it's good and and some of the rulers and
leaders but we don't even know what alistar's
plan would be if he was able to be the ruler
yeah so I guess they would want but they don't
know about that so I'm like why would Charlie
want to I guess what would be the motivation of
hasman Hotel of like the actual physical property
of hasman hotel to inspire people to rehabilitate
you know to Go to Heaven Charlie doesn't know that
heaven's not a good place she went there and she
had questions but I don't think she went there and
was like screw this place I think she thinks that
still there's some beauty there okay but we've
seen more true I'm shocked that they killed Adam
vaggie would know that's pretty [__] up there
yeah vaggie would know but vaggie didn't even
tell her anything yet but vaggie might we might
see that Arc in season too vaggie saying like do
why do we even want people to go to heaven like
of course we want them to be better but mhm and
apparently you go only go to heaven if you die
I think it's it beats the AL this is what it is
Greg it beats the alternative of being gone for
eternity because it's not like you're redeemed
and you go to heaven you're he died and went to
heaven true as opposed to if you die in hell and
then you're gone that's fair I mean but you can
also die if you're soul in heaven apparently
according to this like Angels were killed and
right I just think she wants her people to be
able to if they die go to heaven as opposed to
Nowhere yeah there has to be some type of a not an
alliance but an understanding that forms between
Heaven and Hell and there's that one girl that we
think that we can have an alliance with who is in
heaven who they did the duet with in episode six
you know what I'm talking about Charlie the girl
that Charlie did the dght with the younger girl in
heaven yeah yeah yeah she's got our back she wants
the alliance yeah yeah I think there's a there's a
lot more crazy uh World building to go we haven't
I mean I feel like we might even step our toes
into Earth in the next season possibly yeah if
that's where Lilith is uh and maybe that's what
we determined that Redemption doesn't get you to
heaven gets you back on Earth or something well
for a show about Redemption what I really liked
about what this finale did was like it brought her
back around to Family Matters and uh that you know
for not forgiving others but self forgiveness
as well like a lot of like Heavenly themes but
applied in the status of hell I thought was was
really great you know and I don't know how people
will feel about the finale I like the finale I
did too but it didn't go out with the bang that
I thought it might which was like telling us what
the Alistar situation was uh yeah they left the
little they left a little more seeds dangling and
I I still it it went the direction that you expect
like a big blowout Adam di you're surprised Adam
dies it seemed like he was pretty obvious he was
going to die I wasn't surprised that he died as in
when I asked you like do you think he's going to
die I also thought he was going to die I'm just
saying that if you had told me if you told me a
few episodes like do you think he's going to die
this season I would said probably not because he
seems like such a big villain MH that I thought
they might move forward with but it is cool he's
the big bad of season one yeah Where's God in
all this Where's God in all this Greg well that
doesn't matter we're talking about fiction where
have you heard about simulation Theory you don't
know that this isn't fiction I I would I think
this is a terrible simulation then yeah terrible
that's God's fault I need to sign up for a bigger
simulation need a new deal next simulation uh yeah
the because they don't even talk about God yeah
it's that's something that even the this it's
funny I love the show Supernatural I know you do
and they do there's they avoid they they get like
every religion involved and they mainly Thrive
off Christianity and they have another thing
like angels are bad too as well like it's a whole
conversation it took a while for them to really
talk about God and bring you know that equation
as well they'll always have like crucifixes and
stuff but they never talk about Jesus and I I
think there's like certain subjects that they
kind of stray away from but I think you got to
bring God into the equation like you have to
well we're in heaven yeah exactly so you have to
bring the create the the supposed creator of all
uh into it what about the devil that Lucifer is
but like we haven't seen him as the devil at all
uh this is their interpretation of what the devil
he's still the devil you know but it's just the
interpretation of it of Lucifer himself but I
I like Lucifer stepping in I thought the action
was really cool I'm trying to figure out what
that punches that was missing for me it doesn't
really even come out of reveals there was just
something there that it's better than a Marvel
finale but it's kind of like a Marvel finale you
know I still really again I think it knows it's
getting its season two and sometimes when we're
watching so many movies at the end you feel more
fulfilled because you're like oh okay that's what
that story was but oft times as you know I'm a TV
Junkie at the end of a season one you're like
what that's it what do I you know what do I do
from here yeah well it's seems that Charlie is
going to become a beast a beast a strong leader
and that's what I mean like we were I kept saying
that I think that we're going to see her get more
Unleashed throughout the SE series and then this
one really teased that a lot she even had the
whole tail and everything and she was like hulking
out and and devil form i l it so hot stuff it's
hot there God it's me Greg and Roxy what where
did that come from because uh we're talking about
hopeful for season two and things that are H did
you ever read are you there God it's me Margaret
yeah I'm the guy who would read or did you see the
movie no do you know the movie I know that's the
oh my God what it's one of the biggest movies from
last year Rachel McAdams is in it um it's called
are you there God it's me Margaret it's made after
the book whatever you're saying Where's God I was
still on it it was one of the biggest movies
of last year it was big movie last year yeah
big box office movie really I don't mean one of
the biggest is in like a tent pole that was but
yeah yeah was theater theatrical release cool it
was it's really good um it was um Kelly Fremont
Craig her follow up to edge of 17 oh cool and it's
based on this book that was like it's a book about
coming of age getting your period it's like a book
that most my friends most PE girls I know my age
read it anyway are you there God it's me Greg and
Roxy I'm glad hear we want to see you on hasbin
Hotel season two yeah all right well great WAP up
song I we feel like it was pretty straightforward
it was an action episode but defeated heaven
and I mean yeah they and and I think I really
think what I'm hoping for season two was one of
the best parts that I think about this show that
that I felt like kept ramping up and I do feel
like they kind of dialed it back in these last
couple episodes those last couple became very
straightforward and I liked the complexity and
M and multi- leress of everything they were doing
prior like even when she goes to heaven there is
such a conversation there's a debate about
everything yeah they were able to have more
fun in those episodes because they didn't have to
accomplish as much we were on kind of like side
missions and I think a de like you can really open
up a conversation here of you know the The Duality
of opinions in heaven of what they should do about
hell like there can be a divide in heaven and I
hope they go into that terrain too I I think like
as much as Everything feels celebratory there's
also a lot of complications that can erupt from
something like this you know yeah and and I hope
that they they go there because the last two have
been very straightforward and they kind of played
out in a way that was cathartic at the same time
uh nothing was as the most unexpected thing was
revenges go but that was really unexpected
expected that's bigger than we think and I
think that speaks to the central theme of this
show which is my takeaway of this entire season
and of this show which is who gets to decide
what's good what's bad and and what are like
when we had that episode with the three episode
with the three qualifications right who picks
those and who's to say really and uh on your best
day would you go to heaven and on your worst day
would you go to hell I bet every person probably
on their best and worst day would be one of those
two no matter where you are in that Spectrum so
I think that the serpenta stuff really made a
difference because it leaves me to believe that
this show knows that that's its main theme yeah
well before we go is your Friday really busy yeah
you're going to have a lot of comments to respond
to I can't wait I hope we have hours of free
time I only respond to comments that say my
name because I'm vain and um comments that
are nice because I can't be down in the mud
with the Trolls but those can you can waste
the most time there I know you can go down
a big vacuum and I want to live in heaven it is
a hell I've done it I've done it many times are
you there God it many times you should react to
that movie it was so good okay I appreciate the
recommendation anyway ladies and gentlemen hasb
been Hotel was the finale satisfying for you leave
your thoughts down below ask Roxy questions season
1 has been a a great season a a hotel listen I'm
going to grab some food and work on videos to get
these to these guys but thank you Roxy for joining
me on this journey thank you for having this be
the first show we cover together many more to
come yes many one more to come and and then uh
we're going to old school this time to warm up
the Brain before we film a movie reaction so thank
you to all who have joined for this tier I want to
shout all you guys out individually one at a time
we'll do more than just say your name we're going
get some serious bars starting with Matthew arms
delivering all the charm arms Jack Forest uh in
a Ford tus nice and namari constantly eating
all that calamari Mike Joyce in a rollsroyce
everyone gets a car in my version hope you commit
locked now maybe Ryan Smith the ultimate dark side
of the Sith Kevin Meek in the front seat Adrian
Tim's addicted to playing the The Sims nav deep
sidu uh you can borrow my Subaru real Naga rh's
real Heather gear put it in Heather GE Heather
first gear that's the appropriate version Ian
Simon always be rhyming Jacob Neptune drives the
Saturn Kayla the king always rocking that sexy
bling looks like I'm riding with Olivier ham
got it did it ring ring I'm getting a phone
call from Allan Ling Kier if I removed some of
the letters from your name it would be Kia sento
ju Longoria I aim to bore you I'm going to drive
right off a cliff Rodriguez Ian wreck constantly
listening to back goat Nation could you tow me
to the gas station Lorenzo back ride me faster
differently saying going to hydro plane in the
rain that's still a car thing Marco tun still
always out for the ultimate kill simply faded
tinted windows you got to get a new set of tinted
windows on your car my friend SJ 94 always cutting
right to the core Justin Aston Martin the perfect
one about phone be calling calling and he's on the
phone balling Philip J Smith Jr Mitsubishi used to
make cars remember that just that you just made me
think of that so that's that's for you Jen Smith
hips have a nice withy Melanie LeBlanc Melanie Le
Bronco that's not bad that feel like you would
drive a Bronco too and and also now that I'm
think thinking about it Kevin Meek could have been
Kevin jeep that would have been better but anyway
Kier could have been Toyota Kiera could have been
Toyota that might have been a good rhyme there's
so many options NE tune in next month when I
uh bring a whole boatload more other car uh
references to fits your names we didn't do Tesla
there was nobody got to be a Tesla or a Porsche
or a a Lamborghini and then you just had like
a grab bag of fun and fanciful had the hard job
yeah yes you did you carried this and I commend
you for it thanks guys for carrying [Music]
us